So we got our first look at a post debate
Trump yesterday.
Of course, the debate with Joe Biden took
place Tuesday night.
It did not go well for Donald Trump.
But to be fair, it might have gone well enough
for him to keep his existing support.
I don't think his base will abandon him based
on the outrageous and childish performance
of Tuesday night.
In fact, his base thinks that he won.
So it may not really move the needle very
much.
But what I was interested in was what is Trump's
state of mind?
What is Trump's demeanor post debate?
We saw him tweeting unhinged things, but he
did another one of these Korona rallies last
night.
This one was in Duluth, Minnesota.
And Trump spent a bunch of time recently in
Minnesota where currently Joe Biden leads
by more than nine points in recent polling.
Donald Trump has been insisting he might win
Minnesota.
I doubt it.
But he's spending some time there.
The rally was really, really sick.
I was sort of paying special attention to
what Trump would say about the debate itself,
whether he'd scale up his attacks on Joe Biden
to be even nastier ad homonyms.
But he also said all sorts of other things
that are, of course, untrue.
And in many cases, completely disgusting.
So let's look at it a little bit.
Donald Trump launched directly into straight
up lies by just making things up whole cloth.
He said Joe Biden is trying to cancel the
remaining debates.
Biden has not suggested canceling the remaining
debates.
Biden has not asked for a cancelation.
Biden has not dropped out.
But Donald Trump doesn't care.
He says it and the crowd believes it is too
weak to lead this country.
You know, Biden lost badly when his supporters
are saying he should cancel the rest of the
debates.
Now, I understand he's canceling the debates.
Let's see what happens.
I think that's not going to be a good move.
I don't think that's going to be a good move.
Television with those ratings are never going
to let him cast a unit on television.
This is how nonsense spreads.
Trump tells a crowd.
Biden's canceling debates.
The crowd go.
He goes home and posts on Facebook.
Biden is canceling the debates.
Someone makes a meme.
And before you know it, there's this false
notion spreading that Biden has canceled the
remaining debates and has backed out completely
untrue.
Donald Trump again told this story that he's
been telling about how there was a day, I
guess it must have been about a month ago.
Trump tells the story where he went home to
Melania and he asked, Darling, did you see
the news on TV about my Nobel Peace Prize
nomination and Melania?
This is the story says to him, no, I didn't
see it.
They were talking about a hurricane.
And this time, Trump adds, they're really
dismissive Rinkel of saying they were talking
about rain.
Now, of course, rain was the hurricane that
was devastating Florida, destroying people's
homes, destroying people's lives.
And Trump says they covered rain instead of
my Nobel Peace Prize nomination.
But I told my first lady, I told first lady,
darling, you're going to be so proud of me
tonight.
We're going to watch television and you're
not going to believe a big disco.
What happened?
What happened, darling?
I won the I was nominated for the Nobel Peace
Prize for Israel, Bahrain, United Arab Emirates.
I was nominated again for Serbia, Kosovo,
all different that I was nominated a third
time.
But I said first time.
Second time, I was a little bit.
Yeah, I know.
I love you, too.
But I said to first lady, watch this tonight,
darling.
It's going to be.
And I turned to Lester Holt number to show
I turned to Lester Holt and that covered one
stars about red.
This is just it's the height of narcissism,
isn't it?
How dare the news cover a hurricane wreaking
havoc?
They should be talking about how a Norwegian
right winger or was it a Finnish or Swedish?
Some Northern European right winger said I
should get the Nobel Peace Prize.
Isn't that the story?
Instead of a hurricane destroying people's
lives?
The UN abashed height of narcissism.
Donald Trump then mocked Joe Biden because
Joe Biden takes Corona virus seriously.
And Joe Biden doesn't want to do events for
his campaign.
That risk the spread of coronavirus not a
concern Trump has.
But Trump ridicules Joe Biden for it.
I don't know how many are involved.
This was supposed to be an iron range get
together.
But it turns out big.
You know, Biden has 20, 30 people.
He's got those circles.
Today, he had a little bit more like 30 or
40, but they were too close together.
Sunderman No joke.
They were too close.
34 people right next to each other.
And yet he complained about early rallies.
Now, it's an honor that so many people showed
up because this was going to be a little quickie
just to say congratulations because Obama
closed the iron range.
Imagine making fun of the candidate that's
taking the public health precautions during
a global 100 year pandemic that you mishandled.
Read leading now to two hundred and eleven
thousand deaths, far more than what we needed
to have backwards.
Bizarro World.
In this next clip, Donald Trump tells a completely
implausible story, including what we call
the search routine.
OK.
Now, the search routine is when Trump tells
a story of someone saying something to him.
He will often say, they said to me, sir, etc.
and this time it's about a guy who supposedly
came to Trump so overwhelmed with emotion
about how Trump had improved this guy's life
that the guy was crying.
I mean, it's a completely incredible story.
Take a listen.
A man came up to me, a tough man, a man who
a worker, a construction worker, real worker,
and he looked at me.
This is two years ago.
He said, Sir, you've given us back our life.
And he was crying.
And I said, When was the last time you cried?
He said, I can't remember.
I said, You never cried when you were little,
baby.
You never cry.
This is not a crier.
This guy was tough as hell.
He said, sir, he took our life away.
And let me tell you about Joe.
Joe will reinstitute that ban in two minutes
and we lose.
So you better vote for me.
Minnesota.
Really?
I mean, honestly.
Imagine being a fly on the wall during that
meeting between Trump and this guy, if it
even took place.
Also, this dumb idea that crying is the opposite
of toughness.
Just every lame trope that Trump can't seem
to get away from.
And then here we have just a simple lie.
Donald Trump says he says this in every state,
every time he goes to Pennsylvania, he goes
to North Carolina.
Trump will always say, you had your best year
last year.
You had your best years during my presidency.
And of course, he says it to Minnesota.
Here is this story with Jason.
But let's do it anyway.
But we're going to win so much because Minnesota,
before I came around, was not doing too well,
okay?
I was not doing too well.
Then you had your best years ever.
Now the truth is a little different.
The unemployment rate in Minnesota is now
94 percent higher than when Donald Trump took
office.
The unemployment rate in Minnesota was three
point eight percent in January of 2017.
It is currently seven point four percent.
And that's down, by the way, from its corona
virus high.
So just a simple lie and a simple fact check.
How quaint.
Right.
It's sort of like the old days of politics.
Trump continuing to be obsessed with the suburbs
lately.
Donald Trump ridiculously and laughably claims
here again that Joe Biden will destroy the
suburbs by abolishing single family zoning.
Well, whether we allow Joe Biden to kill the
recovery, you know, he wants to shut down.
This guy says, let's shut it down.
A lot of death caused by shutdown, depression,
dead drugs, alcoholism, horrendous family
fights, horrendous family fires.
And he wants to destroy those suburbs by abolishing
single family zone.
And all of these things are just a horrible
thing.
He what he wants to do, it is stunning how
saying localities should look at the racial
impact of zoning became Biden wants to end
the suburbs.
And now it's Biden will eliminate all single
family zoning.
It just completely disconnected from reality.
And the crowd now, because Trump has been
repeating it for so long, they're used to
it.
They anticipate it.
They cheer or boo or whatever reaction it
is that Donald Trump wants.
And then Trump continuing with the suburbs.
That obsession, Trump admonishes the crowd.
And he says, how the hell am I not doing well
in the suburbs?
So they talk about the suburbs, women and
the suburbs.
I ended a regulation that nobody would have
done.
This brings public housing, low income housing
into the suburbs.
And by the way, just so we can get this rate,
30 percent of the people in the suburbs are
low income people.
minorities.
And so we're ruining this American dream for
everybody.
But he's got a plan.
It's the worst thing you've ever seen having
to do with zoning.
They zone you out.
They build low income housing next year.
House, it's crazy.
And then I hear I'm not doing well in the
suburbs.
I'm not doing well in the suburbs.
Are you people crazy?
Are you crazy?
That's.
It's an unusual way to get the crowd on your
side, isn't it's a strange way to wait to
win votes to say what the hell is wrong with
you people?
Maybe it works for the average Trump supporter.
I really don't pretend to know at this point
what the average Trump supporter wants to
hear from Donald Trump.
But the rallies continue.
And postdebate Trump as unhinged as ever.
No rally on today's calender for Donald Trump.
Upcoming includes next week's vice presidential
debate on Wednesday, which we will be broadcasting
live on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
The week after that is vice is a presidential
debate.
Number two, the week after that is presidential
debate number three.
We've got a one week respite from the debates
and then it's Election Day.
That's it, folks.
So we've got V.P. debate on week one.
Trump Debate Week two.
Trump Biden Debate Week three, week four is
off, week five is the election and that's
it.
OK.
This is the final stretch.
Later on in the program, we are going to talk
about some of the sort of desperate measures
that the Trump campaign is taking.
Tomorrow, we will be talking about incredible
fundraising by Joe Biden during the debate,
record fundraising, raising.
And we will, of course, have continued coverage
of all of this and more on The David Pakman
Show Instagram page.
Make sure you're following us on Instagram